[Music]
so there's a woman you guys can guess
the state cool florida thank you
she is accused of child neglect after
her toddler was found in a soiled diaper
walking the family's pit bull by himself
i mean is that child abuse or is it
animal abuse a child how old is the
child a little child that child is good
you know the age
i imagine a toddler yeah like a
three-year-old or something well it's
wearing a diaper so it's gotta be pretty
i feel like this was a radius thing the
dog wasn't dragging the baby huh no
apparently it's gonna be like a radius
thing if if the baby's still like
within 30 feet of the house
walking the dog no problem no problem to
me why do irresponsible people always
get pit bulls
it's like the choice of irresponsible
families yeah that's true but it seems
like the pit bull is taking care of the
baby hey pimples are [ __ ] great dogs
pit bulls are amazing hey the little
rascals are pretty irresponsible though
you know and they had a pit bull you
know what maybe it's a florida rule that
you have to have a pit bull i think it
is yeah you have to have a [ __ ]
on the freeway oh you see that oh yeah
you don't see that specifically pit
bulls
yeah from like pitbull fights and [ __ ]
like that you don't see it all the time
but you know what i'm talking about damn
no what happened like dogs on the
freeway and stuff like that is that a
glendale thing no
seeing that like up the [ __ ] coast so
like they do the dog fights and then
they dump the body too that's hard so i
heard the freeway jeez yeah when i was
in el salvador sometimes like there's a
bunch of dogs everywhere
and like they're just like uh roman free
but then every now and then you'll see a
dead dog on the side of the highway
that's like just dying of starvation
wait so all dogs who go to el salvador
are just roman free that sounds like all
dogs go to heaven nah but they're all
very hungry all dogs go to el salvador
when i was in bali it's the same [ __ ] it
was like [ __ ] very similar there's
like golden retrievers walking around
like like regular domestic dogs that
people would pay thousands of dollars in
the states all slow emotion golden locks
just like toilets they're on vacation
that could be a business yeah this could
be a business yeah we should figure
something out getting a lot of inventory
from these places it's like three grand
for a golden retriever yeah but then you
gotta buy a plane right you gotta buy it
you gotta save the dogs dude that's what
we have today i saw the same [ __ ] when i
was in yulin it was crazy
what is that when i was
a bib on
there's a whole festival around it
looking at the menu and [ __ ]
so this lady's getting in trouble
because her [ __ ] toddler's got a
soiled diaper walking the dog [ __ ]
filled up how far
from the [ __ ] house that's a really
good question and they say it was near a
canal that the home was near canal
that's really all they're giving us on
that waterfront everything happened to
him
uh no he was fine but so many so many
violations in there what are they
leaving out the part where the dog
dragged him and he's bleeding all over
the place it was just hospital people
are so judgmental dude right if it's
husband he could run the world that guy
walking his dog has bulldog but
this is stupid
that is so stupid
i knew he liked it though
[Laughter]
hey that baby has bulldog
see building up this is the flow i like
you know so cops went to the house
19 times like so this is all this kind
of [ __ ] happens all the time on calls
that involve
19 yeah 19 times on calls that involve
runaway juveniles domestic disturbances
and battery and on april 4th they went
to that same address after child was
wearing a diaper reporting wagon during
outside walking a dog and then they saw
a butcher knife in the driveway
several alcohol bottles in the yard
broken windows covered with cardboard
uh and there are two 15 year olds in the
house as well as two kids ages eight and
six who are all supposed to be watching
the toddler
and she also said um she blamed it on
the other kids
so it's a normal day in florida
kind of yeah just a normal florida day
they just left their [ __ ] out what if
the kid was like the most responsible
the toddler right and then he's [ __ ]
in his pants because he doesn't know how
to change it but he's like judging their
asses he's like all right [ __ ]
you watch this you do the dishes i'm
gonna go to the [ __ ] store no one's
[ __ ] walk this dog out in two weeks
i'm gonna go walk this dog so he's just
out there and he's talking [ __ ] to
himself like these [ __ ] don't
know how to [ __ ] live man he's like
the alcohol balls are empty by the way
i'm gonna go get more alcohol
smoking a cigarette walking his dog and
then the cops come
he goes what the [ __ ] do you want and
they're all like hey baby you know you
have [ __ ] in your diaper and he's like
what else you supposed to do with it
[Laughter]
it's like the stewie of the group you
know
yeah i don't god it's a light
yeah dude it's pretty it's just one of
those domestic uh
situations that you kind of read and
you're like oh my god i'm so thankful
for my parents
so thankful they beat me in the shape
home it was my mom's birthday last night
and i was like happy birthday yeah and i
was like damn man like reading this one
particularly picking this article i was
just like man thank you mom you're a
great mom
i picked this article today because it's
my mom's birthday last night made me
think of her yeah well no it was last
night when i was poor i was looking at
this one and i was like oh man that you
know it just put it in perspective
that's true huh you know what i mean we
got real lucky with our parents
take something like this when did you
guys mom [ __ ] up the most though
that's a good one
that's a really good one
dude i remember i still feel bad right
now because my mom is having this like
flashback moment from time to time and
then she'll just start [ __ ] crying
like i can't believe i neglected you
doing this and i'm like i [ __ ] i'm
over it you get over it like the [ __ ] is
wrong with you weak ass [ __ ] i'm like
the [ __ ]
i had to live through it you [ __ ] like
what do you want me to do
but it's kind of weird because um
every time she does it dude i'm just
like man see this is why i don't want to
[ __ ] come hang out with you because
you're just [ __ ] crying all the time
and [ __ ] i just want to i just want to
have lunch like i'm past it but then now
she has to kind of proclaim yeah and
then i'm like dude that should happen
like years ago and she wants to like
say sorry like it just happened
and then some of the stuff that she said
sorry for i feel sorry for it because
it's like dude you're just you're just
so [ __ ]
you're being so um
like you're beating yourself up and i
have to be like this motivational
speaker to my mom and just be like you
know what though you're learning now and
everything is like better for you now
and the roles are so reverse but it's
it's kind of good to kind of uh to get
that feeling
from someone that like
they
wronged you i guess or they they they
recognize their fault dude now you're
the mom no you got to mother her i had
to mother her full circle though that's
crazy see even you saying that i'm still
like that's shocking
maybe it's because i can't even i'm not
saying my mom did anything wrong but i
can't imagine her recognizing her not
doing something right yeah or being
willing to like verbally communicate
with me in such a way to express that
so like the fact that you guys can even
have a conversation of such depth i'm
like that's [ __ ] crazy it's progress
but also my mom's like a grandma
compared to all your guys's mom she's
like late 70s that's my dad really yeah
so it takes like knocking on like you
know doorstep to be like really really
thinking about what you what you got to
get out it might take like a lot of
people dying around conversation the
worst and best thing about my mom is
that she can't turn off her motherhood
like even when i'm [ __ ] grown as [ __ ]
and she's like oh you know did you eat
yet and like that doesn't oh jesus yeah
well to be fair ken i mean did you eat
today
i did it's a good question i did
yeah we're all worried about you look
you look good no he had a banana today
cam [ __ ] eats a fig and it looks like
he's pregnant dude
keep it coming keep it going
then we will
well you do look pretty young yeah
do you think your mom's deep i think she
has it in her but i don't think me and
my mom communicate well with each other
like she's obviously very affluent
vietnamese i'm not fluent in it you know
what i mean i speak english with a lot
of vocabulary that she has no [ __ ]
idea about so it's like we can't
get to
it's like we have child vocabulary for
each other with her english and my
vietnamese we can only get to a certain
depth like you can't tell her mom
respect my boundaries like she won't
know what that means she'd be like
boundary huh
the boundary man
does she understand that humor when you
like act again i can't do that there
dude you should try it
see how it works out i'm gonna do it
when there's no animals you guys can't
do that together when you're both like
no
she's like wait that's me
disapproving asian mom [ __ ] either i'm
eating too much i'm not eating enough
i'm not sleeping enough or i'm sleeping
too much i'm not working enough or i'm
working too much like it's never does
she does she recognize your dance
ability
like does she go my son can [ __ ]
smoke your son yeah after all these
years she's like what do you do
but you know there was like and i love
my mom for this this is such an asian
mom thing to do right remember when i
was trying to dance it was always like
no don't dance like that you should not
do that the second i like actually did
some [ __ ] and then she would go out to
like boy scout meetings as like a parent
right
we're on the scouting family type [ __ ]
and then all the other parents because
their kids know who i am through like
youtube or tv they're like oh my god
anthony can we take a photo of anything
so the parents will ask my mom
so then my mom can't be surprised she
has to almost shop it you know what i'm
saying it's gotta go the other way can't
be like wait my son you you got me
joking it's gotta be like oh really yeah
let me go grab him for you yeah i'm sure
he'll be fine he'll take a photo with
you you know you basically boosted her
up like yeah with your career i mean she
she didn't make me so like you know all
that's all
does she go to uh events and gatherings
and she's like anthony do the dance
thing do the dance thing i mean now and
make you dance in front of kind of she
would watch this clip and be like what
the [ __ ] is he talking about i literally
made him
i made a huge i show him the ed sheeran
song
[Laughter]
he don't know who ed sheeran is
what accent is this chinese
it sounds like his tongue is frozen
it's cheers coffee is pretty cool that's
a parent's dream though you're a
parent's dream and sharing bro
[Music]
[Music]
foreign